das sieht süß aus
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine trendtorte nämlich
diese Comic Torte davon habe ich
tatsächlich einige schon auf Pinterest
entdeckt ihr könnt übrigens auch auf
Pinterest folgen denn da gibt es auch
immer ganz viele tolle nützliche Dinge
von mir Rezepte oder auch DIYs und so
weiter schaut euch gern mal die
Pinnwände an jedenfalls war Pinterest in
der Zeit lang voll mit diesen Torten
Comic cake nennt sich das Ganze und ich
finde es sieht schon ziemlich cool aus
und es war eine kleine Challenge für
mich denn ich wusste nicht so ganz ob es
funktioniert am besten plant ihr euch
sowas immer an zwei Tagen ein denn ein
am ersten Tag ist immer gut wenn man da
backt füllt und kühl stellt und am
zweiten Tag dekoriert denn die Kühlzeit
ist gerade bei buttercremetorten oder
bei Torten allgemein so das Wichtigste
wenn man nicht kühlt kommt man nur in
Stress weil die Torte da nicht so steht
wie sie soll und deswegen habe ich es
auch auf zwei Tage aufgeteilt deswegen
starten wir jetzt zuerst mal mit einem
Biskuit den gibt es auch schon als
Grundrezept auf meinem Blog und in
meiner App weil ein Biskuit einfach nur
aus ganz wenigen Zutaten besteht
für den Biskuit nehme ich 6 Eier die
sind bereits zimmerwarm 150 g Zucker
etwas Vanilleextrakt und eine Prise Salz
und 150 Gramm Mehl da könnt ihr auch
gerne das backmehl Verwenden das Biskuit
Grundrezept findet ihr auch bereits auf
meinem Kanal da habe ich nämlich ein
eigenständiges Video dazu gemacht falls
ihr dann noch Tipps und Tricks braucht
gebt jetzt nämlich zuerst die Eier mit
Zucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt in die
Rührschüssel und das ganze muss dann
schon wow das sieht echt eklig aus der
hat sich da einfach so drübergehängt
habe auch noch nicht erlebt naja und
dann muss das Ganze für etwa 15 Minuten
richtig cremig gerührt werden ihr könnt
auch gerne ein bisschen schummeln und
könnt sagen ihr macht das jetzt nur für
etwa fünf Minuten arbeitet dann mit
backmehl da ist er Backtriebmittel drin
Backpulver aber wie gesagt 15 Minuten
dann braucht ihr auch kein backmehl oder
ihr macht auch gerne beides und rührt
lange und habe noch Backtriebmittel drin
dann geht er auch schön auf
[Musik]
jetzt ist die Eiermasse richtig schön
dick cremig genau so musste auch sein
also wirklich schön Aufschlagen der Ofen
ist jetzt auch schon vorgeheizt auf 170
Grad Ober-Unterhitze und die backringe
die habe ich jetzt hier schon ihr seht
es auch nicht ganz auf 20 cm eingestellt
sondern auf ein bisschen weniger 19,5
damit ich später mit dem ganachingboard
alles glatt streicht kann das heißt zwei
backringe auf dem Dauer auf eine
Dauerbackfolie und dann auf dem
Backblech und jetzt könnt ihr hier das
backmehl dazugeben wenn ihr normales
Mehl verwendet einfach kurz durch 7 aber
backmehl ist schon gesiebt deswegen
braucht man das dann nicht
und nur vorsichtig unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt hier vorsichtig einfüllen
verstreichen und backen und in der
Zwischenzeit werde ich mich dann um die
Füllung kümmern
[Musik]
für die Füllung habe ich mir gedacht
dass ich Nektarinen und Pfirsiche nehme
und eine Buttercreme da könnt ihr gerne
ein Rezept von meinem Kanal einfach
zubereiten die Swiss Mering Buttercreme
eine deutsche Buttercreme die
französische die italienische ganz egal
für welche Nationalität ihr euch
entscheidet Hauptsache Buttercreme denn
mit einer sahne Creme funktioniert es
später nicht ganz so gut weil die Creme
einfach fest werden muss zum Dekorieren
der Biskuit ist jetzt auch gebacken der
ist noch lauwarm
aber eben noch nicht ganz kalt deswegen
ziehe ich den jetzt hier mal runter
nehmen tortenringmesser und löse ihn
vorsichtig vom Rand also ich lasse den
schon gerne mal 10 15 Minuten abkühlen
und dann schönes Messer am Rand entlang
streifen dann fahrt ihr auch nicht aus
Versehen in den Biskuit rein damit er
eben auch schön ist
[Musik]
ich lasse es jetzt einfach so locker
drauf fliegen damit es nicht ganz
austrocknet der Biskuit darf jetzt noch
schön abkühlen und ich kann in der
Zwischenzeit schon mal das Obst klein
schneiden einfach ein bisschen würfeln
[Musik]
noch kurz die Patient weg
da lacht sie der Biskuit ist jetzt
abgekühlt und wird jetzt schön
waagerecht durchgeschnitten das geht am
besten tatsächlich mit einer tortensäge
oder mit einem Tortenmesser
[Musik]
legt ihr den ersten Tortenboden hier
drauf wenn ihr möchtet gerne auch mit
Marmelade bestreichen
ansonsten eure Buttercreme nehmen ich
habe da jetzt zugegeben ich habe eine
fertige Buttercreme genommen okay
aber könnt doch eine von meinen Rezepten
nehmen
die könnte sogar mit etwas Saft anrühren
also das finde ich tatsächlich echt
praktisch bei der Buttercreme dass man
da einen Saft anrühren kann und dann hat
man direkt da Geschmack mit dabei
jetzt ein paar Fruchtstückchen
ich wollte einfach mal wieder so eine
klassische Torte machen so ganz ohne
fruchteinlage aber klassische Torten mit
Fruchtstückchen müssen halt auch recht
zügig gegessen werden also die sind
nicht so lange haltbar wie jetzt eine
Torte mit fruchteinlage denn bei einer
fruchteinlage wird das Ganze gekocht und
dann werden die Früchte eben nicht
matschig aber so für den gleichen Tag
oder bis zum nächsten Tag finde ich
passt das mit Fruchtstückchen auch gut
mit etwas Buttercreme abdecken und stand
die Torte so Schichten und wer will und
die Torte noch saftiger machen möchte
kann auch gerne die Böden Tränken mit
etwas Likör oder bisschen Pfirsich gibt
pfirsichgeist gibt's das
genau könnt ihr gerne
[Musik]
ich habe da jetzt ein bisschen Pfirsich
Nektar drauf weil ich finde Biskuit
neigt schon dazu trocken zu werden aber
so fluffig deswegen mag ich es schon und
wenn ich so mandelrührteig Böden mache
die sind tatsächlich aufwendiger und die
sind auch luftig und fluffig aber bis
geht es nochmal anders muss ich sagen
könnte auch Kaffee nehmen aber ich finde
Kaffee und Pfirsich passt sehr gut
könnten ja mal so Geschmacksrichtungen
definieren in den Kommentaren so was
könnte womit passen und vielleicht auch
so richtig
coole Kombination weil ich dachte zum
Beispiel nie oder hätte nie gedacht dass
Haselnuss Tonka und Zitrone gut passt
bis ich letztes eine Praline gemacht
habe und die war da Hammer weil ich
hätte halt irgendwie nie was zitroneiges
mit Tonka vermischt
zwar Taube
der Social Media man der schaut immer
mit Musik beschäftigt gehen die Ecke und
schäm dich
[Musik]
dann lasse ich die Torte jetzt erstmal
im Kühlschrank ruhen das bedeutet die
soll jetzt erstmal schön fest werden und
da lege ich jetzt einfach eine
tortenrandfolie drum das muss nicht sein
aber dann habe ich später ein bisschen
einfacher
und Tortenring drum und abdecken und für
mindestens eine Stunde bis zwei in den
Kühlschrank die Tortencreme die kann so
lange bei Raumtemperatur stehen das
macht gar nichts
aber dann bekomme ich eben auch so eine
richtig schöne perfekte Form hin
ich drücke das dann immer gerne noch so
ein bisschen damit sie so an Festigkeit
gewinnt
ich finde so ein Tortenring da gibt halt
echt noch mal richtig gut Stabilität die
Folie hebe ich übrigens auf die wird
gewaschen und dann beim nächsten Mal
wieder benutzen jetzt nehmt ihr hier die
Buttercreme und macht erstmal die Torte
schön glatt also hier am Rand erstmal
alle Löcher auffüllen und dann könnt ihr
auch die zweite Ganache drauflegen und
damit die Torte glatt streichen deswegen
liebe ich auch genau schön Platten
mache ich dann erstmal hier die Löcher
ausstopfen kann
in der ersten Tour und bei der zweiten
Schicht dann schön die Torte glatt
machen
[Musik]
die lege ich jetzt die zweite
ganachingplatte drauf und ihr seht jetzt
hier
ihr könnt die dann genau perfekt
auflegen und dann werde ich später bei
der zweiten Schicht wenn die jetzt
erstmal fest wird im Kühlschrank einfach
die zweite Schicht Buttercreme auftragen
und einmal abziehen und dann muss ich da
nicht so ewig rumstreichen
hauptsache es liegt schon übereinander
wow
kurz im Kühlschrank und noch mal eine
Buttercreme
rein geht nicht gereicht
jetzt haben wir noch ein bisschen mehr
Buttercreme hier und die streiche ich
jetzt hier an den Rand sehr großzügig
ziehe sie dann mit der Teigkarte ab und
habe dann hoffentlich eine perfekt
gerade glatte Torte
[Musik]
dann nehme ich oben die Platte weg und
kann die Torte jetzt oben auch noch
gerade streichen
die war ein bisschen schief
aber die Tortencreme die regelt alles
[Musik]
hier drin ist einfach zu warm für diese
Torte ich musste jetzt noch mal
einpacken und über Nacht den Kühlschrank
stellen denn die Creme wird einfach
nicht fest
zu warme Küche hier ab in den
Kühlschrank damit da mache ich
[Musik]
neuer Tag neues Glück meine Torte ist
schön durchgekühlt sie ist jetzt auch
perfekt muss ich sagen die sieht gut aus
da unten nehme ich noch ein bisschen die
Creme raus und dann kommt jetzt in den
Kühlschrank und ich werde mit der
restlichen Creme die werde ich jetzt
nämlich einfärben und dann die Deko
zubereiten also die kurz in Kühlschrank
kühlen ist echt so das A und O bei
buttercremetorten wenn die nicht gut
gekühlt sind dann kriegt ihr auch keine
schöne Form hin also kommt die kurz weg
und ich hole Lebensmittelfarben
bevor ich es vergesse ich habe immer
Muffins eingefroren aber weiß ja nie und
bevor ich jetzt alles einfärbe brauche
ich natürlich erstmal den Sahnetupfer
auf dem Cupcake
oder hätte ich mir nie Cupcakes
aufspritzen sollen nee einem großen
einen großen weil es dann glaube ich
ganz cool aussieht
vielleicht überlege ich mir noch eine
Kerze
muss mal schauen okay so mini
Spritzbeutel hat ja auch noch nie
einen Cupcake gut ich hoffe die Creme
reicht
jetzt werden die Cremes eingefärbt
einmal rosa dann nehme ich jetzt einfach
dieses pink und brauche wirklich ganz
ganz wenig nur
oh das war schon zu viel
ich nehme ein bisschen was raus
[Musik]
und bei Schwarz mache ich es so ihr
könnt nämlich die Farbe der schwarz ein
bisschen verstärken indem ihr sie
erwärmt das heißt hier gibt es einen
kleinen Teil Buttercreme in ein
Schälchen
denn ich zeige euch mal folgendes wenn
ich das jetzt hier rein gebe
verfärbt sich das Ganze dunkel aber eben
nicht schwarz ihr seht es ist einfach so
ein dunkelgrau wenn ich das jetzt aber
erhitze jetzt gleich viel schwarzer
guck mal hier ist jetzt nur ein
dunkelgrau und jetzt stelle ich es mal
aufs warme Wasserbad
[Musik]
und dann einfach zur restlichen Creme
wieder dazugeben und einrühren
setze ich erstmal die Torte um
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt erstmal der
zuckergussrand da habe ich jetzt die
rosa Buttercreme in einen Spritzbeutel
mit einer Lochtülle gefüllt
probieren wir jetzt einfach so der
aussehen als würde sie runter fließen
das heißt
[Musik]
und hätte zwischen schön ausfüllen
das wird später noch glatt gestrichen
[Musik]
dann hier oben den Rand
ich lasse jetzt erstmal an der Torte
bisschen fest werden und kalt werden und
fülle die anderen auch in Spritzbeutel
dann nehme ich jetzt aber kleine
Spritzbeutel brauche ich keine großen
ich habe ja nicht so eine Riesenmenge
ich glaube sie wird so wie ich sie mir
vorstelle
nie zu früh freuen das ist wie wenn ich
sage oh heute werden wir mit dem Dreh
schnell fertig und dann kommt immer was
dazwischen und dann werde ich die fertig
deswegen
mit hellblau und gelb mache ich jetzt
hier noch diese Streusel
entweder macht ihr Punkte oder ihr könnt
auch so lange Streusel drauf spritzen
ich mache jetzt beides
[Musik]
und ihr könnt hier die Buttercreme immer
mit dem Spritzbeutel nach vorne schieben
mit so einer Teigkarte es geht immer
ganz gut dann sammelt sich das auch
alles wieder vorne
dann Spritzen wir jetzt weiter
[Musik]
okay das reicht erstmal
dann hier oben die Creme und bisschen
verstreichen
dass man nicht sieht das ist so
aufgespritzt ist aber es muss nicht
perfekt sein denn es ist eine Comic
Torte die darf ja gezeichnet aussehen
[Musik]
das sieht schon cool aus und jetzt die
einzelnen Tupfen auch so ein bisschen
glatt und ich nehme dafür einfach diese
Mini Paletten die sind perfekt
perfekt geeignet
so da alles ein bisschen flach aussehen
[Musik]
bis zum letzten
Cupcake kommt
und jetzt fange ich schon mal an mit der
schwarzen Umrandung jetzt müsst ihr
praktisch alle Linien umranden damit
diese Torte aussieht wie eine Comic
Torte das heißt auch hier drumrum um die
einzelnen Punkte und dann muss ich mir
das immer mal wieder anschauen damit ich
auch nichts vergesse
[Musik]
falls ihr beim arbeiten häufig warme
Hände bekommt das habe ich nicht ich
habe eher grundsätzlich kalte Hände dann
solltet ihr die Buttercreme immer auch
mal aus der Hand legen und vielleicht
auf dem Kühlpad denn wenn ihr das lange
in der Hand haltet diesen Spritzbeutel
und der relativ schnell warm wird dann
fließt euch die Creme irgendwann raus
das heißt damit die Konsistenz immer
gleich bleibend ist ich habe ja hier
eine schöne kühle Platte ich kann es
euch immer ablegen solltet ihr sie
wirklich auch mal aus der Hand legen mal
eine andere Farbe wieder nehmen und dann
eben wieder weiterarbeiten aber
grundsätzlich ist beim Backen ist
eigentlich nicht so gut wenn man so
warme Hände hat deswegen vielleicht
könnt ihr auch vorher ein bisschen
abkühlen gerade bei Buttercreme wird es
besser bei Hefeteig sind warme Hände gut
[Musik]
das sieht süß aus
okay damit jetzt aber jetzt muss ich mir
überlegen wo ist die Vorderseite
denn
hier ist die Vorderseite
ja denn der Cupcake muss ja auch
aussehen wie ein Comic
das bedeutet ich muss den auch umranden
[Musik]
ich mm Arbeit
ja
aber wie gut
ich schwitze ja
okay und jetzt hier die Tortencreme
[Musik]
von vorne
die braucht noch sprinkles on top
der hat mich komplett an die Simpsons an
den Donut von Homer Simpson ich glaube
tatsächlich jetzt wenn ich noch
weiße Creme mache um die
Lichtreflexion zu machen dann ist der
glaube ich fertig was man durch den
Bildschirm gucken hier
ja
ich wollte eigentlich noch Süßigkeiten
drauf packen aber ich habe jetzt
eigentlich Süßigkeiten selber gemacht
das bedeutet
die UFOs die da drauf sollten und jetzt
schon auch farblich gut gepasst aber die
muss jetzt essen
gut werfen gehört nicht zu ihrer Stärke
okay ich probiere jetzt was ich weiß
nicht ob es was wird wenn es nichts wird
das muss einfach weg ich probiere jetzt
vielleicht noch den Pfirsich
quasi quasi
auch comicmäßig aufzubereiten also beim
Pfirsich Erde schnell Nektarine
Nektarine bei der Nektarine auch
drumherum die Linien fahren
[Musik]
darf jetzt noch nichts verschmieren
Platz okay 3 2 1
die Kommentare ist fertig
megacool geworden ich bin echt happy ja
was mache jetzt mit dem tschüss die
wollten da auch noch drauf die essen wir
jetzt einfach
[Musik]
Objektiv kaputt
ist fertig
jetzt wird die Torte angeschnitten Tolga
darf probieren Tolk die ganze Zeit hier
mit dabei und hat mitgefederung
also eigentlich wenn sie euch ganz gut
gefällt finde ich könnten wir noch mal
eine comic-torte 2.0 machen und so
richtige Comics noch mit drauf packen
weißt du so eine ganze Fleisch
so also das war jetzt mal so basic und
ich finde dafür dass sie so cool
aussieht ist es relativ
easy bei der Herstellung also man
erzählt ein tolles Ergebnis mit relativ
wenigen Hilfsmitteln man braucht auch
echt nur so ein Spritzbeutel und
schwarze Buttercreme und dann hat man ja
schon diesen Comic Effekt ich meine auf
jedem Bild sieht es ja brutal aus ich
glaube wenn man jetzt so ein Bild
einfach nur schießen würde ja
[Musik]
okay ich schneide jetzt mal da vorne an
denn ich würde dann noch den drin auch
so aus ja ich mache das dann gleich
genau so Linien es sieht einfach so
so krass unecht aus ich finde das wirkt
dann auf einem Foto echt gut
[Musik]
oh das sieht gut aus
wow
okay aber jetzt muss ich wirklich noch
so ein bisschen den Künstler raushängen
lassen und wirklich hier vorne noch
anschneiden
und das Tortenstück dann auch fürs Foto
mit Linien verzieren okay
[Musik]
Schichten als letztes mit einem Lineal
abgemessen
und zwar deine Perfektion
und schmeckt sie
[Musik]
ich bin gar kein Fan von Buttercreme das
weißt du ja ich weiß aber mit den
Früchten zusammen die Anna Creme okay
ich habe jetzt eigentlich nur einen
Versuch weil das muss jetzt halt schon
sitzen das heißt ich mache jetzt hier
eine Kontur
oder
also eigentlich sind wir als Job fürs
Foto
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sieht so cool aus es hat funktioniert
hier ist die Comic Torte oh cool jetzt
probiere ich auch
checken ob sie wirklich schmeckt wieder
teurer sagt und du magst eigentlich
keine Buttercreme Torte aber es hat
geschmeckt
also dann schreibt mir doch gerne mal
wie euch meine comic-torte gefällt und
welcher Comic Charakter ich wäre denn
ich kenne mich mit Comics nicht so gut
aus aber schreibt mir auch gerne wenn
ihr so eine Comic Torte noch mal in
einem anderen Stil sehen wollt dann
überlege ich mir noch was krasses weil
da wollte ich jetzt halt echt mal nur
ausprobieren ob es cool aussieht
die sieht cool aus
willst du den Leuten jetzt erzählen
das dem ganzen Raum vollhaarschnitt
richtig abgefahrenen Sachen
ich bin kleine Anime-Fan
Comics
was muss man da so kennen wenn immer so
richtig Comic Anfänger ist wie ich ich
bin irgendwann stehen geblieben bei
Donald Duck wow ja
ich meine es gibt ja so viele Comics von
Marvel von DC also sogar von Lara Croft
von Tom Rider
auch Comics
so groß wie du
also ich lese mich bisschen mehr in die
Comicwelt ein euch viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen und bitte bitte gebt mir ein
Feedback zu der Torte denn ich bin
richtig gespannt drauf macht's gut bis
dann tschüss
Ski Hulk weil du so
alles perfekt kannst
was macht die die ist Anwältin
und sie weiß es sehr sehr viel wo ist
deine Brille
okay dann bin ich jetzt nicht du wirst
aber auch grün weil du heute grüner hast
ich bin Lara Croft
[Musik]
[Applaus]